okay let's uh it's been a couple weeks
but i do want to get to a new
episode of hatred mail reminder what is
hatred mail
why don't you take some hydroxic
chloroquine for that trump derangement
syndrome
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate
david pakman because america
and because freedom
okay so you know sometimes if people
hate the show this much
maybe this just isn't the show for you
take a listen to this week's hatred mail
and see if you come away with the same
uh
same feeling cockman pacman at it again
the economy is the people don't let this
complacent [ __ ] gaslight you into
destroying the only leverage you have
your votes pacman the virus effect
too much your judgment your loud mouth
will cost you a very high price
your demo rat venom is mind blowing
is all queer like you meaning [ __ ]
stupid thinking only that a demo rats
are the best of the best politicians on
earth
he worst and the most corrupt channel
there is on earth meaning park man
i mean listen i i just don't think this
is the this is the show for you and
that's okay
and i you know i don't i i don't know
different people's
viewing habits for programs i don't
watch shows
that infuriate me i don't watch shows
that i believe to be corrupt i mean
someone who covers bad media you know
i'm on some digests that let me know
this crazy thing happened on fox this
crazy thing happened on oan
but i don't spend my time watching this
stuff if it's not actually things
if it's not not relevant to my work or
something i want to consume just
find something else that's my message
and by the way
terrific opportunity speaking of the
youtube channel which they say is the
most corrupt
we have surpassed 843 000
youtube subscribers we are on the way to
850
000 hopefully then 900 000 and hopefully
then
the big milestone of 1 million
youtube subscribers stunning incredible
when we started this
youtube channel more than a decade ago
you know i i think it took like a year
close to a year to get our first
thousand subscribers we now regularly
gain
10 to 20 000 subscribers in one month
and i have only you to thank so very
much appreciated you can also
take advantage of the coupon code hatred
40
to save 40 on a membership of your
choice at joinpakman.com that's
r i spelled h-a-t-r-i-o-t four zero uh
sign up at joinpakman.com
save 40 percent with the coupon code